cette nuit là les rescapés du foyer
adoma de la fontaine d'ouche ne peuvent
l'oublier pour bouchaïb elle est
synonyme de descente aux enfers huit
étages des vallées dans l'obscurité
totale et des fumées toxiques
un cauchemar maintes fois ressassé le
procès risque de leur arriver
je dis peut-être assez je vais mourir le
compte sera vite et lui dit je descends
j'ai dit je vais mourir comme ça pas que
je vais je vais oublier lucien lui c'est
qu'elle ferait dans sa chambre en
attendant les secours vingt longues
minutes où il s'est senti pris au piège
mais tout cela ils l'affirment est
aujourd'hui derrière lui il ne se rendra
pas non plus au procès même si une
question la cei toujours quoi il avait
pas de gardiens la sécurité de la deûle
a représenté par quelqu'un de vivant qui
pensent à lui tout seul il peut rien la
question de cuite modou lui a perdu son
frère dans l' incendie son aîné a
réveillé tous les étages avant de
succomber aux fumées il a laissé aux
orphelins aux payer nos doux veut être
présent à l'audience pour saluer la
mémoire de celui qu'ils considèrent
comme un héros
ce procès est important pour lui tout
comme pour la communauté sénégalaise
deux garçons qui parle à son niveau
voilà condamnés et mon frère qui est
décédé aussi on va la demande et parce
que ça fait longtemps
la famille qui attend là bas tous où il
arrive quoi il faut toujours pardonner
mais il faut toujours s'attire aussi
paraît-il que l'un d'eux a invité ici
donc il savait qu'il y avait du monde
donc il savait que ceux qui courent un
grand risque de tuer peut-être beaucoup
plus qu'ils en cuir qui des deux
prévenus tenait le briquet ce soir là
pourquoi avoir mis le feu pour faire du
mal ou par inconscience ce drame
aurait-il pu être évité toutes les
victimes rencontrées attendent des
réponses précises à leurs questions mais
sans haine ni désir de vengeance